And the key thing to know for
bag of words is that the word order does not matter.
It's clearly a no, because we are counting words we have no preference to where in
the phrase a word occurs,
which kind of make it somewhat limited compared to really understanding a text.
It's kind of taking all the words and resorting them in random order.
That's why it's called bag of words.
Because you toss them into a bag.
And gone they are.
Long phrases do give different vectors.
So suppose we take the same email and duplicate it.
All the counts go up by a factor of two, and
it's going to be a different input vector.
So to some extent you're biasing yourself to also encode the length of your text
not just the frequency of the words, so the answer would be clearly yes.
And I would say, can we handle complex phrases.
Right now we can't, unless we make extra buckets for
those, which makes it a bit more difficult to preprocess.
Chicago Bulls would count one for Chicago and one for Bulls.
And here's a funny little insight,
when Google first came out as a search engine and you typed in Chicago Bulls.
You saw lots of, of, of references to cities and lots of references to animals.
And so a, a bunch of smart Google engineers to change the dictionary to also
included combined phrases like Chicago Bulls.
So go to Google, try it out.
I promise you you see very few animals and very few cities.